[Música]
aquí comienza el debate de France 24 Mi
nombre es Ángela Gómez Y los acompaño en
este programa para analizar el contenido
del discurso del estado de la Unión
Europea que fue ofrecido hoy por la
presidenta de la comisión de los 27
Úrsula vanderland como se esperaba el
enfoque fue la Guerra de Ucrania y sus
consecuencias para Europa para el
análisis nos acompañan
idílicody mascada que chiti directora de
la maestría en derecho económico de la
pontificia universidad javeriana esto en
Colombia y Luis Antonio huacuja director
del programa de estudios sobre la Unión
Europea en el postgrado de la UNAM de
México a nuestros televidentes les
recuerdo que también hacen parte de esta
conversación dejen sus preguntas y sus
comentarios en nuestras redes sociales
estamos en Twitter Instagram y Facebook
donde nos encuentran como
@f24_es y también Ángela Go f24 mi
cuenta personal la etiqueta es el
numerable el debate f24 en YouTube fue
pueden nuestra señal en streaming y
también saludamos a las personas que nos
escuchan vía podcast no olviden que
todos nuestros contenidos están
disponibles en Apple podcast Spotify
deezer y tuning
entrando en materia uso Lander Legends
se pronunció ante el parlamento europeo
y destacó entre otras cosas una
inminente reforma profunda del mercado
energético europeo esto para hacer
frente al alza de precios de la energía
a raíces de la escasez del gas ruso en
esa misma línea reiteró el compromiso de
la unión con Ucrania y de hecho al
terminar la sesión se desplazó hasta que
fue para reunirse con el presidente
ucraniano Esta es la tercera vez que
vanderley tiene visita el país en guerra
desde el inicio del conflicto y en esta
ocasión el objetivo es abordar con
selenski las necesidades ucranianas Para
orientar como continuará la ayuda
europea veamos
se acerca el frío en Europa y los
precios de la energía continúan
disparados como resultado de la invasión
rusa de Ucrania para sobrellevar el
invierno la Unión Europea planea ciertos
cambios en el mercado eléctrico
comunitario como reaccionar el consumo
de energía ayuda temporal del Estado
separar los precios del gas de los de la
electricidad o limitar los beneficios de
las compañías eléctricas
no está bien generar ingresos y
beneficios extraordinarios gracias a la
guerra y a Costa de los consumidores en
estos tiempos los beneficios deben
compartirse y distribuirse a los que más
lo necesitan
[Aplausos]
aseguró que la Unión Europea Está
virando hacia proveedores confiables
como Estados Unidos Noruega y Argelia
mientras que a largo plazo declaró que
Bruselas quiere basar su consumo en la
renovables y anunció la creación de un
nuevo banco que estimule la inversión en
hidrógeno como alternativa verde
palabras que llegan después de que la
ONU criticara la unión por buscar nuevos
combustibles fósiles como respuesta a la
restricción de garruso una postura
nefasta para el clima afirmó Naciones
Unidas la primera dama de Ucrania olenas
de lenska fue invitada de honor a la
sesión vistiendo los colores de kiev los
mismos que los de la unión bonderleyen
afirmó que a pesar de las consecuencias
levantar las sanciones a Rusia no está
sobre la mesa
quiero dejar Claro que las sanciones
están aquí para quedarse es momento para
la determinación no para la conciliación
los detalles del plan energético europeo
los últimarán el próximo 30 de
septiembre los ministros de energía de
los estados miembros de la unión vamos
entonces a iniciar con nuestras
preguntas y primero quisiera comenzar
con ustedes de Señora indicó Y es que
bonderleyen aseguró que Rusia está a
diezmada y que no es el tiempo de la
apaciguamiento con Putin que tan cierto
es esto estamos cada vez más lejos de
una solución negociada
Pues yo creo que sí aunque hay unas muy
buenos avances y es lo que vemos Esta
semana en en la batalla Pues en la
guerra es que los mismos ucranios en el
Oriente están llegando muy cerca a la
frontera pero pero todavía no vemos
ningún punto de finalización de la
guerra y en este momento pues estos días
cuando en este distancia va a
encontrarse
uno puede ver que eso ya no es una
guerra en Ucrania es una guerra contra
el mundo occidental eso significa que
cualquier solución cuando estamos ya en
estos términos está llegando cada vez
más lejos y más lejos desafortunadamente
Luis Antonio Usted qué opina Rusia está
realmente diezmada como asegura
vanderland
Bueno realmente no lo sabemos y sobre
todo hay que pensar que se acerque el
invierno y mientras más cerca esté el
invierno es un tema que le favorece a
Rusia Entonces yo no apostaría por que
está una Rusia diezmada más bien habrá
que habrá que esperar realmente el el la
prolongación del conflicto está ahí
sabemos Cuándo empezó no sabemos cuándo
terminará y por si no fuera poco el el
clima y el conflicto en Ucrania Pues
ahora también hace unas horas unos días
Bueno pues también se ha abierto
nuevamente esta confrontación entre
Armenia y azerbaiyán lo cual es un tema
que también preocupa a la a la Unión
Europea que tiene eso sí y lo lo vimos
lo en el discurso de la presidenta de la
comisión europea La Apuesta de Europa es
poner en el foco el tema de Ucrania
aunque también esto
involucra un desgaste porque
lleva consigo la la petición casi
exigencia a los ciudadanos de que hagan
el sacrificio ya no solo en términos
monetarios donde Pues hay una inflación
generalizada bastante preocupante sino
que también conforme sea conforme se
acerca el invierno pues ya la
solicitudes a los ciudadanos que pues se
le cierren al agua caliente no viene y
entre tanto uno de los seis grandes
anuncios de la líder fue esta inminente
reforma que pretendería bajar las que
llamó exorbitantes es ganancias de las
compañías energéticas en Europa y que
irónicamente se han visto pues
beneficiadas por la crisis energética
causada por la guerra Cómo se daría esta
transición comienzo con indicó Pues mira
interesantemente estamos hablando de 140
mil millones de euros que quieren
recoger en la Unión Europea y 117 mil
millones de eso quiere recoger de hecho
de unos generadores de Electricidad
Quienes son renovables pero que eso que
están diciendo ustedes están generando
bastante barato pero ahorita están
ganando mucho con los precios y al
frente esto 117 mil millones 25
mil millones de venderían de las
petroleras y gasistas como los llaman
Entonces algo interesante porque no
solamente
petróleo gas y carbón lo que va a estar
afectado pero también
eso no lo vemos todavía seguro muy
probablemente va a ser un capuli límite
lo que se puede cobrar por el precio
también por generadores con base de
bien entre tanto Francia ya hizo el
anuncio de qué va a limitar los precios
del gas y de la energía esto a nivel
país y ahora le pregunto Luis Antonio si
usted cree que esto podría traer por
ejemplo un efecto de látigo en los
consumidores en los ciudadanos de la
Unión Europea
bueno seguramente No ya ahí está
preocupación y por eso ahí está petición
de ahorro a los ciudadanos en un momento
donde también hemos visto que no hay un
acuerdo no hay una unanimidad en el en
el tema energético no La Apuesta de
Alemania va por un lado la de España va
por el otro la de Francia va por otro y
en un contexto de de la Guerra de
Ucrania y esta crisis energética que ya
estaba ahí antes pues bueno la Unión
Europea trata de resolver este este tema
también en la búsqueda de nuevos aliados
en temas no solo energéticos sino en un
ámbito geopolítico
parte del discurso de fonder Legend ante
el parlamento europeo también fue esta
mención a sus aliados a sus socios a la
necesidad de cercanía con aliados
tradicionales de la aso Unión Europea de
libre comercio incluso mencionó Reino
Unido y los países con los que hay
relaciones comerciales donde se plantea
relanzar la relación por ejemplo con
países de América Latina con los que
están se están renovando acuerdos en
particular con México con chile y
veremos si el tema de mercosur también
se puede desatorar viene y entre tanto
algo para destacar de este discurso es
que vanderleyen tuvo mucho cuidado al
referirse a la situación actual aseguró
por un lado que Rusia fracasará Pero por
otro lado aseguró que Ucrania y Europa
prevalecerán entonces deja muy claro
este apoyo Que de momento se desliga al
mismo tiempo del conflicto digamos en un
primer plano en el que se se hace de una
vez la claridad una vez más de que
Ucrania no hace parte de este concepto
europeo decía que ha tenido Pues todo el
apoyo y todo el respaldo usted como ve
estas declaraciones indicó
en todo el discurso hay una dedicación
muy grande lo que es a la situación en
Ucrania para desplazar de ahí el tema
energética y después de terminar con el
tema de democracia lo que tenemos que
ver ahí es que Ucrania en este momento
recibe 18.000 millones de euros de de
apoyo pero en este discurso no están
hablando de nada adicional no hay nada
adicional lo que sería el tema de
militar lo que dará construcción
etcétera hablan sobre reconstrucción de
escuelas pero nada más dicen que Ucrania
va a acercarse al mercado común va a
entrar en el en el tema roaming
internacional Bueno pues ahí ahí se ve
este acercamiento de Ucrania hacia la
Unión Europea pero pero no encontramos
nada más en este discurso relacionado y
en Ucrania además Indicó que va a quedar
muy endeudada una vez que este conflicto
termine y cuando esto sea porque lo que
vemos es una constante pedido de más
apoyo más ayuda más defensas para poder
contrarrestar a Rusia y bueno aunque en
las últimas semanas lo que se ha visto
es una aparente de retrocedida de los
rusos Lo cierto es que el conflicto
parece lejísimos todavía de terminar
pesa Ángela justamente lo que tú estás
diciendo está en el debate Porque
todavía de estos 18.000 millones de
euros los fondos no están llegando a
Ucrania porque justamente los mismos
europeos no pueden hacer la decisión
esos van a ser subvenciones o va a ser
un préstamo de largo plazo este tema de
que tanta plata requiere cómo vamos a
financiar lo que es la recuperación en
Ucrania y en qué momento se termina la
guerra es un es un gran problema
Asimismo como tú estás poniendo a la
mesa y al mismo tiempo Pues en algún
momento voy a tener que dejar de fluir
digamos ese dinero Luis Antonio ustedes
de cómo ve esta financiación ya en el
mediano plazo o hablemos más allá en el
largo plazo porque es que ya contamos
más de seis meses de guerra en Ucrania
el dinero sigue fluyendo hacia ese país
pero la guerra cada día se ve en un
avance más lento cada vez nos llega al
menos noticias cada vez se normaliza más
lo que está pasando en Ucrania
Sí claro
ha habido un efecto de desgaste y
también de desinterés no ya no está
todos los días la noticia ahí y esto
perjudica digamos por un lado
que Ucrania sea el foco de atención
constante
quizá la idea de emergencia se va
diluyendo un poco y por otro lado hay un
efecto también de rebote en cuanto a la
percepción de los ciudadanos europeos
porque los ciudadanos europeos están
viendo que sus sus gobiernos están
enviando armas y dinero a Ucrania
mientras el ciudadano de a pie Está
padeciendo Los costos elevados en sus
bienes y que consumen diariamente y
especialmente en el tema energético Y
entonces empieza a ver un reclamo algo
que por cierto la extrema derecha
aprovecha muy también en sus discursos y
aquí hay otro foco rojo que debe atender
Europa el fonder Legend ha insistido en
renovar esta Promesa de Europa pero
parece que en medio de esto hay un
alejamiento hacia el interés del
ciudadano común del ciudadano de a pie y
luego se lanzan estas promesas hacia
Ucrania moldavia de un posible ingreso a
la Unión Europea lo cual también es muy
lejano cuando menos tardarán una década
si es que entran hoy por hoy no cumplen
los requisitos ninguno para ingresar a
la Unión Europea Bueno ahí hay dos
partes del discurso que usted está
tocando Luis Antonio una es este llamado
de vanderleiden a una renovación de la
manera de hacer las cosas en la Unión
Europea y a una convención de la que
espero podamos hablar más adelante pero
ya que usted habla de del caso de Suecia
donde ella la primera ministra anunció
su renuncia ante la victoria de una
oposición de derecha pues hablemos de
cómo la situación de ese país
venir reflejando la realidad que se vive
en Europa en donde esta coalición de
partidos de derecha incluye además un
partido que tiene raíces neonasis estos
estos Ultra nacionalismos a los que
tanto se les teme y que tanto hacen
peligrar esta cohesión de los 27
Sí bueno totalmente El problema es que
ya no es solo Suecia si contamos hoy por
hoy cuando menos 12 países de la Unión
Europea tienen entre el 10 y el 60% de
escaños en manos de partidos de extrema
derecha las propias selecciones
francesas de hace unos meses en la
primera vuelta la extrema derecha obtuvo
más votos que el partido de Manuel
macrón no vienen en una semana las
elecciones en Italia y también la
extrema derecha aparece que será quien
se beneficie no solo las urnas Pero por
supuesto de esta situación crítica
económica política y y además Pues esta
situación que que vemos de de los temas
energéticos de la inflación que
capitaliza muy bien
Georgia meloni y y aquí hay una una
situación muy importante porque
pareciera que este tema que ha
consentido de alguna manera Europa
por restarle importancia Pues ahora se
convierte en un gran problema
insisto 12 países de la Unión Europea
con un creciente
incremento de
participación de parlamentarios de
extrema derecha y ya pues los gobiernos
estarán también llegando gobiernos de
extrema derecha como lo vimos ahora en
la reciente elección en Suecia el disco
Lo cierto es que la primera ministra de
Suecia Magdalena Anderson ya anunció que
va a dejar el cargo después de reconocer
La derrota de su bloque de Centro
izquierda en las elecciones que vimos el
domingo pasado la coalición de derecha
está conformada por cuatro partidos Ya
lo hemos dicho Uno de ellos con una raíz
neonazi y aquí Quiero preguntarle si
parte de este resultado tiene que ver
con el capital político o que han
invertido los líderes actuales de La
Unión que sea concentrado principalmente
en la guerra en Ucrania con las
consecuencias que ya ha mencionado su
colega a nuestro otro invitado en el
debate
el caso de Suecia es tan difícil porque
hace 100 años gana siempre
socialdemocracia el partido
socialdemócrata en Suecia ahora pasa lo
mismo entonces justamente pese la señora
Anderson su partido gana con 28.3% pero
los demócratas Quienes son los ultras
con el liderazgo de jimm Carson llegan a
un 20% y
sobrepasan a los conservadores lo que
son más moderados tradicionales es una
preocupación muy grande porque los
conservadores tienen todos los votos
pues escaños para
establecer gobierno Pero cuál es el
partido más fuerte adentro de ellos las
ultraderechas y mira
especial lo que hay detrás de eso es un
tema supremamente fuerte relacionado con
inmigración y relacionado con el tema de
lo que es
se convirtió el segundo país después de
Croacia de la Unión Europea donde más
gente se muere homicidios por armas Pues
mira esto es imprevisto es algo pues
inimaginable para un caso para un país
nórdico y especialmente para Suecia
significa hay un descontento tan grande
por los inmigrantes por crimen etcétera
En el país realmente eso conjunto con la
afectación lo que es la guerra los
precios la inflación obviamente es una
bomba atómica lo que se estalló en este
país nórdico bueno el chico Y qué fue lo
que los llevó hasta esta situación usted
misma dice que es una situación
absolutamente atípica para la historia
de ese país Cómo se llegó a estos
niveles de violencia que sí ustedes lo
dijo muy bien estuvieron en todo el
centro campañas y fueron lo que al final
terminó catapultando al partido de
oposición
Pues mira Ángela Es un país de 10.3
millones de personas donde cada cuatro
secos uno de hecho es de raíz extranjero
Y eso no pasó con los 160.000 pesos
migrantes quienes llegaron en Pues en
2015 Pero estos 160 fueron como el punto
culminante un punto culminante y se
estalló una situación donde los mismos
suecos Aunque tenían esta política de
recibir y recibir y recibir Pero ellos
reconocen que no fueron capaces para
integrar estas personas en una sociedad
donde otra vez digo de cada entonces
cinco personas
cada cuatro personas uno tiene raíces
extranjeros esta falta de integración de
estas personas y donde hay que reconocer
que todos estos homicidios en su gran
mayoría existen entre
quienes están en crimen organizado donde
desafortunadamente estos inmigrantes
origen sirio etcétera tienen una
prevalencia una mayoría es una situación
donde si uno mira el discurso de Fender
hoy y ahí otra vez en Llama por tener
más solidaridad en tema de de los
inmigrantes es un tema muy difícil bueno
Luis al final estaríamos hablando O
estaría usted de acuerdo en que estamos
hablando de una Europa que sigue
teniendo que enfrentar sus viejos
problemas de migración después de tener
influencia en otras regiones del mundo y
que esto rebota con esta crisis
humanitaria enorme impensable y que
hasta el momento pues Europa no ha
encontrado la fórmula para poderla
manejar la guerra en Ucrania simplemente
se sumó a otra a otras crisis
humanitarias que ya vienen de muchos
años décadas
sí totalmente a ver Sigmund bauman decía
que estamos viviendo las consecuencias
de errores cometidos durante décadas y
lo que vemos ahora es la consecuencia
justamente de distintas crisis desde la
crisis económica del 2008 pasando por la
crisis que provocó el brexit dentro de
la propia Unión Europea y después una
pandemia con efectos devastadores en lo
social o en lo económico y ahora una
guerra no y y claro el más afectado es
el ciudadano insisto no que ahora hay
una desafección mucho más intensa con el
tema político y esto es lo que han
capitalizado muy bien los partidos de
extrema derecha que sean ordenado que
han planteado una estrategia mucho más
pragmática para llegar al poder mientras
este pareciera que el problema no no
existe o se o se trata de de aminorar no
de de restarle importancia al ascenso
del extrema derecha esto se ve con
Claridad en países como como España
mientras la extrema derecha va ganando
terreno se muestra como una extrema
derecha descafeinada lo vemos en Italia
con Georgia meloni que un poco sigue la
fórmula de Marín le pen en este sentido
Pero que está La amenaza ahí también la
extrema derecha se ha dado cuenta que ya
no va a rechazar a la Unión Europea en
el discurso lo que quiere hacer es
entrar en la Unión Europea Y desde ahí
no quizás hacerla implosionar y Esto va
a ser un problema importante hay una
crisis democrática también muy seria que
se está viviendo en la Unión Europea
mire si me permite a propósito de eso
quisiera pasar al segundo tema que usted
menciona en algún momento y son estos
cambios que podrían plantearse a partir
del discurso de hoy uno de los anuncios
que se cree que podrían causar más
movimiento a mediano plazo el tipo fue
el del llamado a una nueva convención de
la Unión Europea de ese órgano que reúne
a las instituciones comunitarias a los
gobiernos a los parlamentos nacionales y
que busca reformar los tratados de la
Unión Europea sin embargo no está en
manos hacer esta llamado o esta
situación la convocatoria está en
potestad del presidente del Consejo
europeo charse Michelle Usted cree que
esta convocatoria podrá materializarse
próximamente
no la escuchamos se cerró su micrófono
ya ya lo escuchamos
ella dice que tal vez Es raro en este
momento de tanta turbulencia llamar por
lo que esta convención europea la la
convención europea se llamaba cuando
hace muchos años con el liderazgo de
hecho Alemania quisieron establecer la
Constitución de la Unión Europea ahorita
está llamando por algo digamos en este
en este orden de ideas y ella en esta
parte del discurso está hablando también
mucho sobre esta conferencia sobre el
futuro de Europa donde la participación
ciudadana tiene una importancia muy
grande es una parte un poco
gaseosa como como poco difícil de del
mismo discurso de ella está muy al final
al final ahí como como metido
yo veo poca posibilidad de este tipo de
movimientos de este tipo de de
actuaciones de este tipo de reuniones en
este momento en la Unión Europea claro
para pintar que tenemos que unirnos y
hay un espacio para eso para que
realmente ocurra yo tengo precauciones
no Pero además desanimar a los países
que buscan sus candidaturas o que ya
llevan muchísimos años siendo candidatos
y aquí le quiero preguntar a usted Luis
Antonio porque una cosa es lograr en
determinado caso que se hiciera una
convocatoria digamos de esta magnitud en
momentos tan turbulentos y otra cosa es
que los 27 pudieran estar de acuerdo en
esa unanimidad que se requeriría para
hacer cambios sin embargo cree que
eventuales modificaciones o la promesa
de esas modificaciones podrían traer
Esperanza para los candidatos entre
ellos Ucrania de que ya expresó
múltiples veces que quiere unirse a la
Unión Europea
Sí es muy difícil Ucrania no cumple
Ninguno de los requisitos llamados
requisitos de de copenhague para
ingresar a la Unión Europea y menos en
una condición de guerra pero es una
promesa que se le que se le lanza a
Ucrania para
pues para para que se sienta cobijada en
medio de de una guerra cuando la propia
Unión Europea sabe que está muy lejos
tampoco hay consenso dentro de la Unión
Europea en el sentido de unas nuevas
ampliaciones ahora están pagando Incluso
el costo de de una ampliación como la de
2014 un poco complicada un poco
descompuesta y justamente el caso de
países como Hungría o como Polonia que
se han salido del redil de los valores
de la Unión Europea pero desde hace
mucho tiempo desde hace casi una década
donde la Unión Europea Se tardó en
reaccionar para sancionar a estos países
ahora es quizá demasiado tarde y
plantear la renovación de los tratados
justamente para modificar Este modelo de
unanimidad que de pronto se vuelve un
lastre es muy complicado El antecedente
es el tratado de Lisboa que pues se
tardó muchos años o más de cinco desde
el planteamiento de tener este llamado
tratado constitucional hasta que se
materializó en el tratado de Lisboa que
fue también un proceso muy desgastante y
muy complejo lo cual se ve muy lejos
ahora el poder concretar una una reforma
a los tratados fundacionales de la Unión
Europea en este momento claro Pero
además el chico
vanderleyen repite esta idea ya
expresada por macrón algunos meses atrás
de ampliar las asociaciones con otros
países aún cuando estos no pertenezcan a
la Unión Europea de ampliar digamos su
eje de ma y su influencia en el mundo
Usted cree que en estos mensajes que
envía uso la bandera Lee en los que por
supuesto habla mucho de unidad habla
mucho de una respuesta rápida y pues
habla de una fórmula diferente para
manejar las cosas entre los 27 si haya
cabida para que se idee una fórmula que
permita más cercanía con estos países
que quieren hacer parte
hay mucho problema político y mucha
turbulancia en en los balcanes lo que
hasta mencionando etcétera significa que
esta como nuestro colega dice está
esperanza lo que eso podría significar
para estos países eso puede ser
importante pero pero otra vez yo veo eso
muy débil en el en el discurso Porque si
miramos El ejemplo de Turquía pues no
menciona Turquía pero dice que porque
estamos hablando de unos países con los
cuales todavía no iniciamos estas
negociaciones Turquía en ningún momento
lo lo menciona pero lo lo dice por qué
pero si miramos como el ejemplo de
Turquía
estos países Pues en general no pueden
tener mucha esperanza y Georgia
específicamente por su ubicación
pues tan cerca Rusia y Ucrania es un
problema Entonces Georgia es un problema
más grande para pensar de ser parte de
la Unión Europea yo
más bien como entenderlo es una forma de
que aunque usa la frontelligen está muy
cuidadoso de no hablar sobre este mundo
de dos de dos polos lo que está
desarrollandose y esta pronunciandose
Rusia y China y por otro lado Estados
Unidos Unión Europea y Pero yo
entendería más bien estas estas
acercamientos eso dándole la mano así a
estas regiones más cercanas físicamente
a la Unión Europea adentro de esta gran
estructura geopolítica
pasando a otra parte del discurso Luis
Antonio wonderley en aseguró que la
industria rusa está diezmada sin embargo
lo que hemos visto Es que la ganancia
petrolera de Putin por ejemplo apenas se
ha visto afectada Europa redujo su cuota
sí Y además con un costo muy alto para
su ciudadanos y para una crisis que en
este momento no no logran todavía
resolver pero entraron a otros países
simplemente hacer la compra y pues aquí
también juegan mucho los precios y y y
los acuerdos de producción
no sé no no cree usted que el mensaje de
vanderley no podría ser un poco confuso
en tanto que está dando un poco un
discurso de victoria de que se está
ganando terreno de que Rusia está
haciendo vencida además pues insistiendo
en que las sanciones internacionales
están aquí para quedarse y que están
surtiendo su efecto realmente lo están
surtiendo
no O cuando menos ya no O no tanto
porque tampoco son sostenibles estas
estas sanciones a largo plazo y la
reacción de Rusia ha sido pues cerrar la
llave del gas que tiene una afectación
importante hacia una Unión Europea que
hay una afectación al ciudadano pero
también al medio ambiente Porque muchos
países de la Unión Europea han regresado
a los combustibles fósiles ante esta
emergencia no evidentemente también hay
una guerra de narrativas y por eso estas
contradicciones del discurso de fonder
Legend Sí un poco triunfalistas Y tal
Pero insisto Mientras más avance el año
la ventaja para Rusia la capacidad de
presionar a Europa va a ser mayor no y
en esta guerra donde también la Unión
Europea fue empujada por por Washington
para estar en el en el frente no sucedió
Ya esta autonomía que conservaba en el
seno de la otan esta propuesta que había
hace años de
recuperar una política de defensa común
pues ahora pues hay que guardarla en el
cajón porque la otan prevalece y la voz
cantante la lleva Washington y en esta
entre la guerra de narrativas y el
acomodo multipolar no de Estados Unidos
china Rusia pues la Unión Europea trata
de encontrar su lugar y por eso de
pronto voltea hacia regiones que había
descuidado como en el caso de América
Latina bueno y entre tanto el chico Ya
vamos llegando al final pero es que se
mantiene muchísimo este esta imagen que
entrega la Unión Europea de firmeza y de
unidad al menos desde sus dirigentes y
lo vimos con los colores utilizados por
algunos de los dirigentes de la Unión
Europea la propia Úrsula wanderley en
que se vistió con los colores de la
bandera de Ucrania una invitada de honor
entre el público estaba la primera da de
Ucrania Así que mientras que de dientes
para afuera hay un mensaje claro de
unidad y fortaleza puede que esto no no
sea consecuente con con lo que realmente
está pasando ya en términos prácticos en
la Unión Europea Ustedes deben Cómo
evalúa estos mensajes visuales que nos
entrega curso landerley en el día de hoy
en general
este discurso el día de hoy es muy
importante porque es dándole las cuentas
de lo que lo que está haciendo El
Ejecutivo al parlamento y también como
diciéndole que aquí hasta el futuro qué
es lo que quiere presentar
como la mitad de su su periodo y y pues
hay que hay que Mostrar resultados y
adentro de estos resultados yo creo que
uno de los puntos que lo que no tratamos
y yo quiero como como como llegar a este
punto y mencionarlo es ahí está el este
fondo europeo de soberanía lo que sí
mencionamos relacionado con el hidrógeno
Ángela tú estabas mencionando pero esta
política Industrial propia lo que está
ahí mencionando fander Legends y una vez
bajar la dependencia de Pues de la Unión
Europea de otros países que ahora las
dependencia no lo dice así que la
dependencia después de petróleo no sea
la dependencia de China sobre son los
materiales etcétera etcétera pues esto
está ahí yo lo veo muchísimo más
preocupaciones y como base de esta
preocupación diciéndole Mira acá No hay
más que unirnos no porque realmente
estaríamos tan Unidos estamos bastante
dispersos y hay muchas fuerzas que
quieren acabarse con la Unión Europea
pero justamente lo que lo que dice es
que se puede eso es como visualmente si
nosotros somos capaces como una unidad
pararse por Ucrania
debemos ser capaces de unirnos realmente
nosotros entre nosotros los 27 muy bien
y ya me quedan unos 30 segundos eso Luis
Miguel rápidamente sus Luis Antonio
Disculpe sus conclusiones
bueno sí evidentemente es un tema muy
muy complejo habló fonder Legend de más
colaboración con otras democracias no la
interdependencia es la apuesta y al
mismo tiempo es el lastre pero es que
esta interdependencia que tiene la Unión
Europea con Rusia aún y con china pues
hace que la situación actual sea
compleja y muy crítica en un momento
particularmente complejo en general para
el mundo y en particular para la Unión
Europea Pues bien es uno de Luis Antonio
huacuja y el chico se quede de masacre
para France 24 en el debate hasta aquí
llega nuestro programa pero nos vemos
Próximamente sigan en France 24
[Música]